so
uh so in this second part i'm gonna be
focusing on econometrics in options in
particular
it was that branch of the of the figure
where we had continuous actions but now
this table we will impose more structure
that we're in a in an auction
um
so
i'm going to be focusing uh primarily in
identification estimation in
first price auctions
and then i'll briefly talk about other
works that go beyond uh the first price
auction setting
um so first price auctions are
important for instance many of the
procurement auctions are first price
auctions and so that's
examples where these things have been
applied
in empirical papers
so
what's the goal we
have deployed a sealed bid first press
auction
where people submit a bid the highest
bidder wins and they pay their uh
their bid for the item
uh we'll assume that
bidder's values for the item are drawn
from some distribution f
that's common
and what we observe is the submitted
bits for the auction and we have
multiple such samples of different
auctions that happened
and the bid vectors that were submitted
and we're going to assume that the bits
that people submit come from a symmetric
based nash equilibrium
then the identification question is if
we observe
the bid distribution
of that symmetric base nash equilibrium
let's call that g so this is the
distribution of bits under symmetric
bases equilibrium
can we reverse engineer and i and and
calculate f the distribution of values
so let's first try to argue that yes you
can do it you can reverse engineer and
there's a one-to-one mapping between f
and g
and if i give you g you can tell me what
f is
and that will also give us a an approach
for estimation if we have samples from
the
distribution and not don't know exactly
the whole distribution
so the symmetric equilibrium
you can write the following uh
equation
if a player
imagines that he is some other value z
and submits
based on the equilibrium strategy of
that other
values
z so submits a bid of s of z
then whenever
they win they're going to pay s of z
their value is v so this is their
utility whenever they win
and their probability
of winning
is the probability that all other
players
have a type
that's smaller than z
because it's a monotone symmetric
equilibrium if they have a type smaller
than z they will be bidding also lower
than z and so i'm going to be winning
now if this s is an equilibrium it must
be that when i'm maximizing this
quantity over here
the value that i'm gonna getting be
getting for z is my value v right so i'm
going to be behaving as if i am my value
when i'm maximizing my utility
so these are the first order conditions
in the case that z equals v that is our
request exactly
so let's write down the first
recognition of this objective
and evaluate it at the optimum which is
v okay
so we take the derivative of this
this is going to be what we get out
and we evaluated that v it has to be
equal to zero
and then you can solve for v
and you will get that v is
uh
you can write v as a function of the
equilibrium bit the derivative of the
equilibrium bit and the distribution of
of player values and also the density of
the player of that distribution
now you can also do a change of
variables
say b which is my b is s of v that's
right
uh
the distribution of bits let's write
down the density
is the probability that a random draw
from that
s of v where v is drawn from f
is uh
smaller than b so it's the probability
that some random draw v from from f
is smaller than the inverse of b
so the uh
density the the cdf of the distribution
of bits you can write it as a function
of the
cdf of the distribution of values
and the equilibrium and the inverse of
the equilibrium strategy
and similarly the density of the
distribution of bits
you can take the derivative of this
equation here and you can write it as a
function of the density of the
distribution of values
and
some property and the equilibrium
strategy
now if you go up to this equation over
here
and make the change of variables
we're going to
v be the inverse of some bit b
and uh
s of v is equal to b
and then the nice thing here is that the
the
s prime divided by f
is going to be equal to the density of
the distribution of uh
bits
and in the in the numerator you're going
to have the cdf of the distribution of
bids you have this
sort of nice cancellation due to this
formula
so what does this say it says that
my value the hidden value
which is the inverse of the equilibrium
strategy for the bit that i observed
can be written in a unique manner
as a function of the bid and the
observed distributions so these are the
distributions that someone gives me
these are distributions of bids
and now
given those distribution of bids if you
give me a
a bit of a player
i can give you what your what the their
value was right that's what this says it
says that if you give me what b what bid
you submitted and you also gave me what
is the equilibrium cdf and pdf
i can then reverse engineer and tell you
what that hidden value is v
if that symmetric modern equilibrium
assumption was satisfied
okay
so because you can do that then you can
essentially estimate
the
cdf and the pdf of the distribution of
values because for every
bit that you observe in the sample you
can reverse engineer what their value
was
if someone gave you the equilibrium cdf
and pdf
and so now you essentially have if in
the population limit you essentially
have samples
from the from the from values
and then it's a matter of saying i give
you samples from values you can find
what the cdf is and the pdf is
you can also write it down formally
based on these mappings but
that's the the idea right so
that means that the distribution of
values is point identified if someone
gives you access to the distribution of
bids
are you going to discuss right
briefly yeah
so
then this gives also a rise to a
reasonable
estimation strategy
if uh given that uh you told me that if
i if i give you this
the cdf and the pdf of the distribution
of bids
then i can
roughly get approximate samples of the
values of players
what i can do to estimate
i can estimate the empirical cdf
given a empirical distribution of bibs
i can estimate an empirical pdf using
some standard kernel based estimators
uh
so this basically sort of counts in some
you know like
stylistically it just counts as
you know splits the space into bins and
counts how many things are in bins but
it does it in a smooth manner
that's a kernel density estimator
and so this will be consistent at some
rates
and then i can uh
out of curiosity
doesn't matter the the kernel what it
would be
[Music]
for so as long as it satisfies some uh
derivative conditions that seriously
optimal nonparametric rates for
estimating pdf but yeah it is something
that typically people are using
that's just meters yes you know then you
have also you need to tune like a
bandwidth and things like that there are
other tuning procedures
this is more of a more standard like
which kernel are using uh typically
you know um even if you just use like a
standard like plotting package out there
like in a python or are you like you
will have some kind of density estimator
in the back end with some optimized
bandwidth to give you a nice
density function so just to be sure
instead of doing
a histogram and finding
the portion beans you're trying to find
something that will interpolate also
yeah you're trying to find a smooth uh g
function right
you're not gonna yeah you're not gonna
do a step function
uh
so if i understand correctly s was not
known right in the s
you end up learning s as well in the
previous setup
no
so uh
you were not told what the equilibrium
is right
i think the question would be
as equation it is you feel that for
different beats
you learn the inverse of the strategy so
you
you can you could like you know you do
get this so you could try to invert it
true
but yeah like uh
yeah
yeah
yes
so yes yes
i mean you don't use it
you don't argue about like estimation
rates for for
for this per se but you're saying how
accurate is the value that i got from
that version and especially when i plug
it into the second stage where i
calculate the cps impedance
but yes this also give you this you can
pick a list maybe you can pick a list
that gives you the inverse of that
and so
but it has to be that the assumption is
that it is a symmetric and monotone
equilibrium for all this calculation to
be correct
yes so then given uh
these estimates g capital j hat and
small g hat i can do a plug-in like plug
them into that formula and get an
approximate estimate of the value of a
player
which is going to be approximate because
this is not really the correct
distribution of bits
at equilibrium it's only an
empirical analog of them
and so for every
sample of
of bids in my data i'm gonna get a
sample
from the values
and then i can define similarly
empirical analogs of the cdf of the
values by looking at how many values
fall below every year every week and
also do like a kernel
based estimator of the density
so that's the approach proposing this
paper
gpv paper
this is a heavily sized
[Music]
is
you never say say okay now i have a
distribution of values i also have an
approximate estimate of my
s
let me compose them and see if i get g
block
because i feel like the whole formula
that you came up with is based on this
uh monotonicity of s function yes
and i'm just wondering if that's okay
like data on like using kernel method to
estimate distribution of the beats and
then
they're not like
having like a weird change let me take
this line because it might be that if
you do the calculations here you you
might always be getting uh one of them
but like uh let me take it offline i'm
not sure that it will be a problem if
you take the data but what you
what you end up with and it might be
some benign assumption on the
on the estimates
yeah anyway so maybe by taking the
derivative of respect to
b you'll see what uh what you need from
the estimate to be
monotone but i mean the g's are gonna
cancel out
i don't know yeah it's like uh not to
yeah
ah to do online
and then there's also the question what
dates you get uh
and
the paper provides some non-parameter
grades subject to reliable conditions so
if the
density of the values has are uniformly
bounded continuous derivatives then you
can get
rates for the
density of the distribution of uh of
beads that scale slightly worse than the
the rates that you would get if you were
actually observing
samples from the from the values
directly so you instead of
uh getting n to the minus r over to r
plus one which is what you would get for
density estimation and non-parametric
density estimation in 1d you get like a
slightly worse exponent in the rate so
um
and that's because
to estimate the density of f we need the
uh that depends on the derivative of the
estimate of the of the density of g
and uh and this extra derivative that
you're taking is what leads to the worst
rates
i believe it's in the
uh of the
of the cumulative
the video it's a point it's not like a
so this is not total variation this i'm
sure that's uniform
even the constant depends on the actual
distribution so it's like the rays that
you get
depending on the object yes it's not
like uh it's more of a it's like the
computer science approach which is like
some absolute constant that does not
depend on the distance
but it's more like uh
[Music]
you know the order depends on the
distribution you're trying to estimate
correct
this is what happens
like the system
[Music]
[Music]
we assume some further bound on those
you could cover worst case or very close
um
okay
i'm gonna uh this will be also gonna
work if only the winning grid is
observed but i'm gonna skip that and get
to the next uh
to get the next section so another
notable literature is uh
going beyond the independent private
value that i mentioned so there's this
uh seminal work of athene hill that
looks at
affiliated private values
but
for second price and ascending options
where the winning price and the bidder
is observed
but
primarily only asks about the
identification question and not the
estimation question so just tells you
when is the
distribution of values point identified
if i give you the distribution of bids
uh
no that is more work than there is an
estimation i think
[Music]
uh
and estimation strategies
more recent papers
[Music]
another paper looks at what happens if i
give you uh say if i look at ascending
options but bids are observed only in
increments which is typical in ascending
auction so the price goes up by
some minimum increment of say five
dollars or whatever and so then you
don't really observe you don't have like
a continuous strategy space
uh even if my optimal bid is is 5.5 i
only need to be either 5 or 10 and that
leads to
problems
where because of that discontinuity of
the bid space you uh you get partial
identification of the private values you
only can only infer a set
and uh of
of cdfs where your true cdf would lie in
so you don't get point identification
if you want like a more complete
treatment of structure of the current
state of structural estimation in
auctions there is this book by parse and
fong that goes over all of these
different
streams
website
independent private values
so some main takeaways from that leaders
is that close from solutions of
equilibrium bit functions in auctions
allows for non-parametric identification
of the unobserved value distribution so
in uh
[Music]
you can non-parametrically as opposed to
the types of estimation strategies we
had in the previous part where we made
some parametric assumptions on the
on the private socks here you can
non-parametrically identify the private
value distribution
uh
and there's this sort of like easy
two-stage estimation strategies where
you estimate observed bid distributions
and then uh plug them into sort of like
an analog of the best response uh
equation and get back uh the
distribution of values do we ever really
expect
fully independent maybe not but maybe
you could have like observed
characteristics of the object and then
some things are known and they're all
shifted and then the private socks or to
those values are independent so you have
common sectors that are known maybe even
to the auctioneer
of the quality of the object and then
the other stocks are independent
like my cost of production if i'm in a
procurement option could just be
independent
for different firms
yeah
typically used as a model of minor
settings for non-durable goods goods
it's not not an oil field but like you
know i want to go to the movies so
we've got the movies and that's over and
to where i'm gonna go again
let me say
okay
one way of thinking about this is that
if i observe um the vibration of my
rival is that gonna tell something about
how much i should value
but in advertising auctions the idea is
that if i acquire uh pay of eyeballs is
you know how much i value those i was
gonna depend on how much my diabetes
recycles i think you know typically the
answer is no right
unless my rival knows about how much
this guy is going to spend on my out
then which is right so it's not
completely um i think uh yeah
yeah so for this like yeah so sponsored
uh service and stuff is a good example
of another one
i see i get the eyeballs and i get some
value out of it but like for example
being an annoying thing if i know that
you you know you you know you have a
good signal
you have
and then
the rate for estimating density of the
volume are
so
in the remainder i'll go into some into
new into two papers uh from the
computer science literature that tried
to
tackle some of the drawbacks of the
literature so far
uh
the first one is trying to address the
issue of these slow rates
and say
uh if we really care about understanding
optimizing of our space of mechanisms
with respect to revenue we don't really
need to estimate those value
distributions
and their cdfs and their pdfs at the
slow rates we can get root and rates for
the for estimating the revenue of any
counterfactual auction in that class and
so we can optimize at faster rates and
the second one was a paper we did with
eva and dennis where we're trying to
relax the equilibrium assumption and see
what we can say when you do value
inference
in online adoptions uh
subject to the assumption that players
use a no regret learning algorithm
connecting it to the topics that were
discussed so far in the tutorials
so the first
paper aimed to identify a class of
auctions
such that by observing bits from the
equilibrium of one option
you can infer the equilibrium revenue of
any other auction in the class
in a fast sort of like
the fast estimation rate
and such that the class of auctions that
we consider
contains
auctions with high revenue always for
any distribution of values compared to
the optimal option that we could have
run even outside of the class
so the class of options that were
analyzed
were
[Music]
the ones called rank-based options so
these are
position auctions where every position
has a weight in a decreasing decreasing
weight
and bidders are
are allocated to positions based on
their relative rank of their bid
so the kth highest bidder
gets allocation xk
uh
and um
and pays xk times bk
and
the feasibility constraint is that
because i'm
the amount of
allocation i assigned to the top
uh
tau bidders should not be more than the
allocation that's there in the top
tau slots
so
so this is the class of options
and it is known that for regular
distributions the best such rank-based
auction is uh to approximately
is a two-approximation to the optimal
option so it achieves at least half of
the revenue of the optimal auction
for uh the given distribution of values
just to be sure that the best rank is
with the meaning
is a specific
auction model or with the meaning that
if we get the
what does it mean the best run well if i
if i can choose the w's
oh
that means okay
if i can uh
if i can sorry uh any if if i am
constrained to have this visibility
if i can choose yeah okay um
the optimal w's in the auction that is
the meaning of the best ram
based
auction
no i think it's
can you explain
yes
[Music]
so i have this uh uh
this slot somewhere on the wn
uh with these weights okay and
video submits i can
do the weight capture
the weight capture say you know the
first slot has a probability of click of
0.9 the second slot has a probability of
click of point date
it is arriving
and submit bits and i and sometimes the
auction does not look at the uh at the
actual value of those bits just looks at
the the rank
okay so the top bidder
this is a paper clip
yeah i mean you yeah
yeah you something if you want a story
yes but like uh
uh it's just a class of auctions yeah
so um
the top bit there is gonna be allocated
to these
bits based on some uh
is going to be randomly allocated on
those
slots with some distribution the second
highest bidder is going to be allocated
to the slot with some other distribution
and so on and so forth
overall they're going to get some
allocation from these
assignments
uh and that allocation is going to be xk
which is sort of like the uh
the pro you know like the total
allocation that they get from each of
those randomly assigned slots
uh and um
no no xk is the sort of like the sum of
those uh allocation probabilities
all right so you can think of the uh
this is the sort of like the mechanics
of the auction but you can also think of
them in it equivalently as each bidder
gets in some total allocation xk
uh
and
paying first price so xk is sort of my
total allocation time bk
but because this xk come from randomly
assigning bidders to these slots
those allocations have to satisfy these
sort of like prefix constraints that i
cannot allocate to the top tau bidders
more than what is there in the top 10
slots
is
uh this is maybe uh
the confusing statement maybe this is
the this is the class of options you
just need to look at the uh these last
three bullets but this is sort of like
what how you can how you implement it
um
and i think the optimality is not what i
said before it's sort of like a model to
all auctions with such visibility
constraints uh what is the uh what
optimal revenue could you have achieved
okay
um and the constraints here is that you
know like you only look at the round of
the beats uh here
and you're also allowed to you're
charging first price
just to be sure
their locations are
a continuous number between zero and one
or the
zero and wi so that means that
it's dividable the item that i am okay
and you can think of it as
mechanistically as your as a probability
so so what is it
you know
it's not
the your typical feasibility
the
what's the overall location across all
the bridges like why
is it
so if i look at the bottom three bullets
there
it's hard i mean uh the bottom i don't
know
it's i guess the first price and
the last two builders it's the first
price of
that it's not that my typical is a big
constraint
because it uses
graphs right
so another is is that
if i'll give you those probabilities can
you come up with consistent
implementation
uh
for those problems so this feasibility
understand ensures that
for
those that exist
like ranking and some uh
you know i can choose any way to assign
those slots to readers and this is just
what comes out of and their constraints
is that
uh this these are the assignments they
are physically different things like
that it's just an assignment and the
space of
allocations that come out have to
satisfy these
if all i'm doing is ranking people based
on their things
so every
rank-based option
can be viewed as a new position auction
with a different set of weights that
satisfy
these prefix feasibility constraints
uh
and um
so uh every yeah like you can view every
such rank-based auction has a new
position auction where these are the
weights of the position auction i'm
assigning
people to positions and they get
uh wn bar or w2 bar based on the
position that they're allocated to so
there's no randomization
and though so the auctioneer's
optimizations over such modifications to
the setting
and such position auctions is also
equivalent to running a mixture over
k unit options where
the probability of running the k unit
auction is the difference between this
w k bar and w k plus 1 bar
so you can so after all these
manipulations that all of these
rank-based auctions that we talked in
the previous slide
are equivalently are equivalent to
choosing
a mixture
over uh k unit auctions
uh pk
and so um
where i run the kth unit auction with
some probability pk and these pks are
things that i can optimize over right
subject to the constraints that are
coming from the original feasibility
constraints
so optimizing of a rank-based auctions
is equivalent to optimizing over the
space of randomizations over k unit
auctions whereby k unit auction i mean i
have
k equally valued units it really has an
allocate it has a location of one and if
you get one of those units you get an
allocation of one if you don't you get a
location of zero
uh
and you pay your bid if you are
allocated a unit right so this is a
single k unit auction
and so then the question is uh to
calculate the revenue
of any rank-based auction it's
equivalent to calculating the revenue of
any such k unit option for the
distribution of
of values of the player in the setting
so we decompose the revenue of any
rank-based auction into
mixtures over revenues of rank-based of
k-unit options and so it suffices to
calculate the expected revenue rk of
each of those k unit options
so the main question that was uh asked
in that paper is that if i give you uh
one rank-based auction
and i give you a bid from the
equilibrium of that rank-based auction
can you calculate the revenue of any
other such k unit option
which would then allow you to calculate
the counter factual revenue of any other
auction in the class
yes
yes so they're uh the way i mean so it's
a fresh price option right so you're not
using the truth in this at all
[Music]
in
what
i don't mean
[Music]
like the
when you say distribution over unit
options you mean
i have a set of allocation rules and
price rules yes and i put a distribution
over those
i announced a distribution then people
have to bid
right so
how do they fit when facing uh
distribution yes and we're going to
assume that more than equilibrium
again but the point is to get rid of the
slow energy
sorry the slow rate that we were getting
for the pdf
for this quantity over here which was rk
so if we don't care about getting the
pdf of the values in this mode of
equilibrium and we just care about
estimating rt
which is the
the revenue we would have gotten for
that listing for whatever distribution
of values if we were to run the k unit
option
then
then we can optimize over that space of
auctions
so the
the approach that was used is again
trying to write the best conditions
but now uh
does uh does the transformation of
variables and instead of
talking about uh
values we're gonna be talking about
quantiles of values
so
uh instead of talking about the actual
absolute value of the player we're gonna
be talking about uh
it's one tile which is equivalent to the
rank of a player if i were to order uh
sort of like the person's dialogue there
right in the top 10 percentile that took
15 percent down and so on and so forth
and the otherwise is useful it's also
because the uh the uh first there's like
a they want one nothing
and also because they um uh
the
auction only uses ranks
and the equilibrium is symmetric this is
only really only what matters what you
know what percentile of the distribution
you are
so you can write a similar formula that
you don't want to deviate to any other
uh
big and you can arrive after first order
conditions of the singular first order
condition the first a similar inversion
equation
that's the one that we arrived in the uh
and the analyzing the gpv paper where
the value of the player
is their bit at equilibrium
and here uh
the
the
of the bit
uh
is roughly connected to the
density in the severe
now the nice thing is that
this one is over here which is the
allocation probability as a function of
your quantile and the other and the
delivery of the allocation probably
there's a function of your point out
are known from the rules of the auction
um
because the auction only uses ranks and
the equilibrium is uh monotone these are
sort of like uh
uh quantities of the auctioneer uh
that we know just from the rules of the
auction
what is the your probability of
allocation if you're in the top 10
percentile which would also mean that
you're in the top first 10 percent out
of the of the bid distribution and that
is just the rules of the auction so this
we don't need to estimate we can just
plug in
and the only thing that remains to
estimate from the observed data are b
and b prime and the
which is sort of like the b of q you can
think of it as the inverse of the cdf of
the distribution of bits
and b prime is the derivative of that
inverse which will contain both cdfs and
densities so b prime is really the
problematic part because it contains a
density
of the observed distribution of bits
so uh if we want to get rid of the slow
rates in something we need to get rid of
that derivative which will be estimable
only at slower rates
um
so you can see also these mappings here
uh b of q is really the inverse of the
cpf d prime is one over density
uh and so um
so
the main message of the paper is that
the quantity of k
depends only on v of q and another b
prime of q and this will lead to fast
rates
and
uh
the reason that you can do that is uh is
because the revenue is really an
expectation over quantiles
of uh
of uh
of quantities that
that contain the estimated value that we
covered
so
even though for recovering the actual
value of a player
you
crucially depend on u prime when you
calculate the expected revenue in
another option
uh
even though v of q enters there they
recovered me it only enters into an
expectation and that expectation will
smoothen out the objective
and but by doing some integration by
part you can get rid of the derivative
in that quantity and so it's this
smoothening that comes out of the fact
that we're looking at an expected
revenue quantity and now that the actual
recovering the actual value of a
particular player
that uh
that gives you the uh smoking and this
just does this during integration by
parts from the from the glitch
with this you can get one of our written
rates
for not revenue rk
since b of q is essentially
the same as estimating a cdf the cdm of
the distribution bits and invert it
of course you need to for the inversion
the node mess things up
you need
some assumptions about the probability
of allocation of your mechanism and the
first paper required that the mechanism
have a strictly monotonous location but
that was dropped later on using other
tricks in subsequent papers
so that's the main idea
because many times we might hear about
quantities that are so like expected
values
of
how to estimate quantities we can
get rid of the slower rates and get
faster rates
of curiosity
it was a mathematical record game
theoretic change to avoid the
strict positiveness
just because it seems interesting how
you
make it happen that it is always
so the main message of the paper is by
isolating the mechanical design to run
based options we can achieve constant
approximation with optimal revenue even
if we could run any other option and
estimation rates
of revenue which of this option in the
class are good energy
so um
and so this allows if you are building a
system that optimizes
covering this option you can do it with
fewer samples you can do any testing
between options with
and succeed with your samples
um so in the the last part i'm going to
be briefly also connecting to the
previous tutorials and talking about
what if we drop the equilibrium
assumption and assume that
players play according to some learning
algorithm can we still do some form of
econometrics and reverse engineer the
private values
so in this paper we analyzed repeated
strategic interactions like in another
auction setting
where for a finite time horizon uh
players are learning over time
we're not going to be looking at this
dynamic market
i mentioned the previous
session but we're going to be looking at
no regret learning behavior
so we're going to be assuming that the
actions of the players that we observed
satisfy the knowledge property and by
now i guess we've seen what no regret
means in many tutorials so i'm going to
be
going fast
uh
so given that we this is the only thing
that we assume about the observed data
can we reverse engineer and learn the uh
the values of the players
uh and basically the the approach is
that these sets of inequalities are
going to give you an again a partial
identification of the parameters that
the of the underlying parameters
primarily because you also have this
wiggle room epsilon here which
you don't know uh exactly what it is so
you don't know exactly what
how the level of regret of players have
and so um
the not regret assumption is basically
going to give you a set of inequalities
that your true parameter needs to
satisfy and there might be there might
be multiple um
values theta that satisfy this slack
best response constraints
uh
so just a quick question
about the setting is this a repeated
interaction with the same set of players
yes yeah so assuming like a sponsors
instruction where we live on that same
keyword all the time so you learn and
you're learning simultaneously on both
strategies and values
yeah so here we're gonna assume like
there's a private body that you know
uh that your athletic advertising knows
the private value but you don't really
need to for another thousand to work you
don't really need to know the value you
just need to get like bonded feedback
every day
to respond uh you know like and then you
can produce learning algorithm
the value stays the same
[Music]
yes
maybe the most uh
respective uh
with the meaning that i want to
to buy something today if i don't have
it today maybe it's more important for
me tomorrow
yeah like the the value for a click
of an advertiser remains the same for
safety that we can analyze
which is the value of someone visiting
and average users are visiting the the
webpage
and buying something
so the assumption is that rivals are
playing
conditional on their value or the
drivers are playing with them
rivals could be playing anything as long
as i am satisfied with your condition
i'm going to infer your private value
so for different values of epsilon these
constraints are going to be giving us
different
sets of parameters that are
rationalizable and then you can uh
basically what these constraints are
going to be giving us a set that is the
identified set and then from samples you
can try to estimate that identified set
well we're looking at particularly um
auction settings and say sponsor search
auction settings
where players have some value per click
and the utilities uh have this
quasi-linear form
uh where this is your value for a click
this is your allocation probability and
this is your payment
um
then
these identified sets are also going to
be taking some nicer forms because you
have this you're trying to identify the
rational lies of the set for this value
bi and you have the sparse linear
particular utility
so back then we analyzed nine frequent
big changing advertiser uh its
advertiser has bids on many keywords uh
and studied the the data for a period of
a week
uh these were the types of data that we
were looking at and we were getting sort
of rationalizable sets which for the
particular type of utility you can solve
is gonna be this convex compact sets and
the question is okay if you want to
predict the value for a player what do
you do like what is the level of regret
that is reasonable and what point
prediction could you use to say
perform a prediction in the future
back then we proposed that one uses
the lowest
value of regret subsequent work of
naughty and
and nissan
proposed like fundal uh quantum regret
solution to this uh
to this problem where they chose some
distribution over
over points in that lower end of the
curve
um
[Music]
some evidence that this could be a
reasonable solution concept we were
observing that the regret over time was
dropping from one week to the next for
the recovered value that we
observed
and if you're saying okay so is this a
reasonable assumption that people learn
uh based on these no regret rules over
time uh it's hard to do that just by
doing the empirical strategies like me
find the recovering the private spanish
um
one thing that you could try to do is
not only recover private values but also
try to predict future bids from vast
behavior based on such structural
assumptions that people are playing
based on their low regret uh rules and
so in a more recent work what we did was
to
simultaneously try to impair both the
update rule that they were using in this
framework
and also the private parameters in the
utility
and particularly we looked at uh one of
the most uh
widely used uh
sort of like online learning algorithms
so online grade and descent and it's
generalizations of all the regularized
leaders that many people
talked about in the previous tutorials
is going to be in order that algorithmic
utilities were
continuous and concave which because of
the randomness of the auction many times
they tend to satisfy this properties at
least for a large
region of the beads
so this gives you
some
formulas of how the bits should be
looking between two periods of a player
and then using the data you can infer
the parameters of those update rules
which is sort of like the step size and
the private volume and use those
parameters to extrapolate in the future
and predict beats
what is this thing about random stuff
studies
i think one way to view like uh fitting
a model that fits this data is to say
that
is a
you know what
what is the interpretation of the error
if you run this regression
you can view it as some sort of like
random step size or you can also do it
as
the value changing
over time this is the
noisy yeah no this is like if you're
trying to fit the data to this you won't
fit you perfectly right so uh when you
run the regression it's gonna be an
error how what did that error be coming
from
um
we did we try to see how well it
predicts
the
the key uh
place to look at
[Music]
this one over here where the most
important thing is how does it predict
when the test distribution is different
from the trading distribution which is
the more important part where as i was
saying these structural methods could be
more relevant when you're trying to
predict out of sample so here we try to
say let's look at the two
periods of uh
two days where like two periods of
during the day where the the
distributions of bits are very different
so day and night were very different so
let's train models on the single solely
on the day data and predict the builds
of players on the night data um and over
here we were observing that uh
for instance in the series prediction
where you try to predict the whole
series of bits of the player in the next
few days
um
this is the best you could do with
machine learning time series approaches
in particular this profit algorithm from
facebook
and you see that ogd based methods
perform even better than the some
state-of-the-art time series prediction
methods from massive learning
so even though lgbt is a very simple
parametric model he was performing
better than these more complicated fancy
machine learning approaches
when there was a covariate shift and
when there wasn't it was comparable
let's
understand so by serious prediction you
need several steps in the future yeah
and step ahead is why
i see your last bid i predict your next
period
so let me conclude when i when i think
of some potential point of interaction
within the tcs community and the
structural economic theory literature as
uh things that have already been done so
far are in terms of objectives like work
and revenue
and combining the approximation bonds so
these are some papers that have already
been there so instead of looking at
recovering distributions of values you
can just look directly at whatever
you're trying to maximize
um the other thing is computational
complexity proposed economic methods
many of the methods that i mentioned
especially in the dynamic
game setting were very inefficient when
you're trying to implement it many of
them use some grid search methods
whether you just search over a grid of
parameters in the d-dimensional space
so finding more computational efficient
alternative estimation procedures
many of the
economic
methods
are not applied to game structures that
we have studied exhaustively in the
algorithmic game gear community such as
routing games or simple auctions and
maybe we can look at uh different
classes of games that we have studied
from economic
perspective
especially when the game models have a
combinatorial flavor like combinatorial
options econometric theory in options
for combinatorial options is a pretty
open
area
[Music]
and then we can look at computational
learning theory techniques uh
and online learning theory techniques
applied to econometrics like
you know recovering
distributions with uh more benign uh
distribution distances and with better
finite sample uh errors and
more generally uh looking more at fine
and sample properties of our estimators
which is more what we try to do maybe in
in the cold using the computational
learning theory community but maybe more
stylized settings than the ones that
have been analyzed in econometric theory
papers
that's it thank you very much
we went a bit over time but let's take a
you know questions that you may have
yeah
i was thinking about
conceptually the last exercise one way
of executing it could have been
thinking about the patient and uh
updating life as learning so think about
agents immediately interrupting and
doing patient updating based on the
observed beat
so you're doing something else right so
you're and so what's the right way of
thinking about these you know one
possibility could be
i'm thinking about a market in which
these learning algorithms are deployed
instead of the innovation ratio that
they don't want to predict exactly yeah
because most of these automated building
tools are doing some form of you know
online learning algorithms especially
because in these markets the the
mechanism is very obtained and the
market the feedback is very opaque it's
not i really know all of the
like all of the mechanics of the
mechanism or how i'm allocated here how
i'm located there many times the
feedback is in the form of you got this
many clicks and you have to pay this
much
so uh it looks more like i submit a bid
i get some utility feedback and this
looks more like a an online learning
setting where you know like i said with
bleach and i get back to this black from
these black box what the utility i
derived
and that's where exactly where um you
know these are algorithms
were designed for
um
and so yeah it might be hard to form
beliefs about exactly what's going on in
the
bid matching uh algorithm in the auction
or in the you know keyword matching and
all of these or like i was matched here
i was not the informed beliefs about all
of these so that i can basically update
given the
price i was charged and the number of
clicks i go
yeah
so one thing that you could do with this
exercise you could sort of tap no if you
have a good good feet there would be
sort of evidence that indeed
not regret learning
yeah that's what we tried to do with the
big prediction that was one place where
you could have like you have you're
trying to predict now you're predicting
better
uh fit is always a bit hard to like
because you have this partially
identified
structure and so you could fit
like it's okay whether what fit means
when you're in uh this particularly in
fight setting
uh
the other question is that you know like
what level of regret are you saying is a
good fit or not because you can also
choose like what level of regret and
that's why we're showing you know like
there were people in most players you
could rationalize the beats with a small
level over here
so that was a meaning of fit
and in most players we would see that
this smaller than smallest level of
regret would drop between two weeks so
somehow
that would be another instance of that
the regret is going down
um
those of these were the figures that i i
saw and that's
one of the
adversarial way like building
trying to teaching something that would
eventually be
but then if you've got a thing right now
you go back
back to actual equilibrium
in some sense like here you're hearing
this in the marketing
may be disconnected with that and i was
thinking if you know that everyone else
is playing ftrl uh but
you will not play uh is there something
extremely better that you can play
one flavor of such results is like a
mod has some results when people play
like that the auctioneer can
manipulate and get revenue that would be
that's an unstyled result if the
auctioneer knows what they're playing
exactly these things i can
uh push them in the right direction and
extract the old welfare of everything
but here i guess i'm not saying that
like people know that they're playing
the other players playing a particular
type of algorithm it's like playing any
algorithm that could have smaller grid
which could be anything
so then it's unclear what attack i can
do if that's my knowledge set maybe if i
know exactly like in the other the final
setup where i was saying i the other
player is using grain in descent online
maybe i can do an attack but if all i
know is that they're using some no
regret it's not clear what the attack
would be
all right
let's open it up